my kids yeah they kind of insist on it
[Music]
um
uh i mean was there an f i it seems
alive on
on my screen but i'm not actually
watching the stream i have chat open and
chat sometimes it's still alive when the
stream is
when the stream is f but uh looks like
we're back
um i've heard that the karaoke should
only be played by players above
2000 as the positional subtleties are
too hard for low-rated players to
understand
i am not sure it's true about any
opening honestly it's a question of
putting the hours in you can definitely
get adjusted to
to the strategic points of most likely
you you would not be you know you know a
world-renowned specialist in the opening
but i don't think you can just
completely or you know outlaw
any opening for players under a certain
rating that would be
a sad thought to me i think the caro can
be played at any level
oh crunchy or creamy peanut butter i
actually don't do peanut butter at all
so i
don't have an opinion but and like when
i think of peanut butter
it's it's creamy i don't think i've ever
had crunchy so
bye guys see you tomorrow
i don't know what prompted that but i am
extremely apologetic nobody nobody
wanted that
are you are you team crunchy i know what
there is no team creamy
it's just wrong i'm not exactly team
creamy i've just never had crunchy idea
as a high asian
i usually don't get into food arguments
like
milk i understand it's a personal choice
people don't like to talk about it
in public and they're somewhat
embarrassed
to admit that deep down they know that
barista oat is by far the best
milk or milk adjacent product but creamy
or crunchy peanut butter
i don't know it's just so obvious to me
anyone with a moral compass
should see clearly there too i i
definitely
like congratulations makes me makes me
mad
sorry sorry i didn't mean to get all
political
fair enough uh don't don't really you
know have a dog in that fight i don't i
don't eat peanut butter
um never really had peanut butter
you know in in in the house when i was
growing up and we never bought any for
our kids either so
it's not a very you know russian
delicacy
we do condensed milk around here around
these parts
and you know for proper aristocracy
there is boiled condensed milk
do you have condensed barista oat
probably i mean i've never done any
research i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised if such a thing existed
but not not my particular field of
expertise
it's not too late no peanut butter and
just a house of empty
house of actually much boxes to play
with yeah
yeah you're describing it too uh to a t
uh doji as they
as they actually used to say when i was
growing up there was this saying
uh hard childhood wooden toys
so yeah compared to to my childhood of
specifically empty match boxes and
nothing else you know wooden toys is
is a an unattainable dream
haven't we come full circle on the
wooden toys
pretty much yeah i think i think they're
back in back in vogue now
[Music]
bullet is also back in vogue the last
portion of this match
has just begun magnus carson with a
commanding
lead and the oneplus one
section should not change that our
teammate will have to win pretty much
all the games to have a chance
which is just not happening
yeah i think uh we all we all know how
it goes when magnus is 10-5
up after after the blitz portions and uh
with the with the one-month section
uh ahead he is a extremely strong bullet
player so
yeah you you don't really give him five
points odds before the start of the
bullet
i bet peter has opinions on david foster
of all this yeah
i have i have the that book on my
nightstand that has been on my
nightstand for the past five years
i don't think i'm ever touching it
honestly i'm too scared
um
just not happening see dad
[Music]
who the hell what's the wallace no i i
think he is still around
but i have read the book i thought yeah
uh he is the okay yeah that's uh and
apparently it's uh
yeah not not a particularly cheerful
subject either i was not
something wrong
yeah but apparently i i did read a book
which was compared by
somebody who's literally taste i sort of
trust
to david foster wallace which is a a
book called all the wrong moves
uh uh on the topic of
you know being addicted to chess and
chess addiction from uh from a
standpoint of somebody who is not very
good but loves the game on reserve with
me
speaking of all the wrong moves carlsen
has gotten into trouble here after rook
f8
nice little combination yeah 94 jack is
very clever he's still worse but
he would have been in more trouble if he
didn't spot that
[Music]
i have actually read gravity uh
gravity's rainbow but
i can't say much much has registered
with me like i've
i need to start reading in a more
thoughtful manner because
things just don't stick with me but i
did read it
there's a debate who's more well read
peter is way more well read than me
by virtue of reading when it comes
to trash tv though i'm way more what's
the word
more watched possibly yeah
it's unclear yeah vlad is actually
of course poker books i did read poker
books peter
uh i have a a kind of a low blow here
available to me which i will refrain
from making maybe or maybe i won't
refrain from making it i don't know i'm
still
undecided depending on how mean are you
you are to me in the next five minutes
wow now now i kind of want to know but
i'm also afraid
yeah well i mean you said you you you
actually read some poker books so
there's an obvious comeback to that
right
not only did you did you read them you
also wrote some
that is true yeah i'm the pamela
anderson
of book writing
in what we i was going to ask we both
wrote more books than we read
yeah that they used to say that about
brezhnev uh
so you you know you can choose whether
you want to be pamela anderson or
brezhnev of
of book writing i think i'll go with pam
yeah i think i i had a feeling you will
stick with your original
original choice there finally some
gruenfeld what's going on here
knight d2 is fashionable right i think
bishop takes d2 is is slightly more
fashionable but 92 also
also exists yeah supposed to be fine-ish
for black i think but
not without its perils
i'll be watching this with great
interest because i have a feeling i
might have to cover this position for
the course and
having a bit of a clue on what magnus
thinks about it is going to be quite
valuable
because we've seen magnus has been
playing nothing
but cutting-edge theory throughout this
match
rookie 7 computer does not agree with
the world champion
yeah i guess bishop d7 is a bit of an
issue yeah that this rook might never
actually
uh get back home
[Music]
yeah i mean if he if he just decides to
i mean
i'm not suggesting that that will that
will sound a lot more incendiary than it
is meant in but like if if magnus loses
the first three
and this particular game for now appears
somewhat self-inflicted honestly he
white is not really supposed to be
trying to equalize in which p3
grenfell's when the queens come off
although
it's only ten to six
and he's worse is it worse maybe not
anymore yeah i think i think maybe
uh vlad did not uh did not pick up the
exchange in the most optimal manner at
this point on this
bishop f6 we're being told here could be
rookie 7 hang on isn't hm
yeah i'm not sure also bishop d6 here i
don't know i don't know what flood is
doing
and now white is probably just better
because that pawn on d7 will survive
regardless of
maybe not entirely regardless of what
you're doing but
bishop g3 maybe black makes a draw but
it's it's going to be an uphill an
uphill struggle even
even to make that draw and um
that is not much fun considering that
magnus
quite clearly uh did something quite
questionable early on
yeah this is probably just bad now oh
yeah
b3 rook b5 and then the a pawn runs now
say yes to defend this
this is this is not good yeah i think i
think you end up losing this even if it
is uh
holdable to begin with you you still end
up losing this in a blitz game
or a bullet game yeah you just
eventually you blunder something and
and the position collapses
yeah h5 check is a bit of a threat so
maybe magnus actually managed to misplay
to such an extent that now he has to
trade pieces
that's very clever by by blood actually
you can't you you can't keep the pawn on
the right free you
h3 is quite clever yeah i didn't see
that yeah this is missing
i assume oh it's a drum yeah king
king e7 and membership c7 was also very
efficient but yeah
yeah now the king of h5 has no squares
yeah it's just a very easy drone
not even going king e7 there i don't
know why
yeah magnus magnus does play this just
like i guess just to finish the game
obviously we're
we're not trying to win anything
he doesn't seem very concerned about
keeping the game going as long as
possible
maybe he is yeah no i don't think so i
think
plus four and with no real indication
that he is in any trouble he is not
going to
you know artificially inflate uh inflate
games here
no real need to
[Music]
the new fad magnus is trying to promote
yeah this
is weird let's give you a tempo for no
reason checks
i guess in order to play e6 here i guess
that makes some sense but if you
really want the queen out of the way
yeah okay
yeah i guess there's some logic to it
actually no i was
i actually was on the verge of asking
you and then they started playing and i
never had any time
to return to that topic i was good
before if the queen takes the rook
recaptures
and grabs the b7 pawn so magnus castle
just
retreats quietly queen b3 our team is
trying to use the semi-open file
but cuts and gets this queen out of the
way knight a4 attaining knight c5 is
possible but black could just meet it by
b6
civilization plays knight e2 l4 g3
carson stops it by going knight f5
and here comes b5 the so-called minority
attack
but will it lead to any weaknesses black
knight on d6
skipping the positions well defended
queen before queen b6
carlson has equalized here no particular
problems
so probably slightly better for black
maybe even if
if all the rooks come off yeah no issues
and more time on the clock as well so
seen any good movies recently
uh not in a while now i've
have i even watched any movies recently
i've been i've been
catching up on my tv backlog let me
check with my
movies directory are you on letterboxed
what is that it's a platform where you
can track what movies you watched and
rate them
and people can follow you and then we
can approve of your ratings or
disagree with them uh
no i'm not and uh and also it doesn't
seem like i've watched much in a way of
yeah what is that question sort of gave
away you probably weren't
magnus carlsen going for b5 b4 here
fearlessly weakening
the c5 square in order to grab more
space on the queen side
and build a potential past pawn now f6
to kick this knight
not only away but also away from the
defense of the d3 pawn
he takes the pawn white still has some
activity and
potential mice quite a lot of activity
actually a
lot of four coming next yeah this is a
sharp position
you know judging by the fact that uh of
the movies i've watched the
the only one i appear to have saved for
potential re-watching
is burning which i've watched
maybe a year and a half ago yeah it's
not
not been a particularly productive year
for me also i told you to watch burning
so yeah
that recommendation does not help me at
all yeah i know yeah
i'm still very grateful to you because
yeah that was that was one of the best
things i've seen you know
that was long violence of me to share
that knowledge about bernie
yeah artemis is winning again but you
know
probably not going to i think it's good
enough
i mean yeah
[Music]
yeah this one this one he probably does
win although yeah
it gets kind of touch and go somewhere
around yeah like i there's four queen e4
though yeah 24 is maybe a
strong move three hang on did you ever
see the movie constantine peter oh
this is too exciting sorry i'll ask you
about constantly
yeah i i don't know i don't know if you
believe what you just said yeah but this
is uh
this is now very much a game
i have watched constantine maybe even
more than once by mistake wow
free will uh is that
a question whether i've watched
constantino out of my free will or
yes yes at least i mean for the first
time definitely yeah
i actually kind of like the you know the
genre of
kind of good bad movies or i mean
for a given value of good obviously
it's interesting because our dear friend
rustam kazantranov has watched
constantine
27 times and he's he's not done
yeah it's a it's a known phenomenon like
i
recently i've stumbled uh across an
article
uh praising demolition men as
it's a great movie
[Music]
when he was much younger i think watched
demolition meant something like 40 times
that makes perfect sense to me i don't
know if he's still
here demolition man but he definitely
used to watch it
at you know every every opportunity
[Music]
uh still plus four for magnus and the
timer is running out
somewhat time is running out queen c7 we
are playing another version of the
cardboard structure
this time via the caraca this is a
dangerous system especially these early
eight trees recently have caught up
a lot of momentum and ethics bishop d6
is also what fedex likes to do in such
sectors
it looks ugly to me but it seems like
they've done their homework and
concluded
i'm also i've seen this before but i'm
still extremely surprised by this idea
that you can go knight a3 and black
doesn't take
kids and their knights these days yeah
kids these days isn't this just horrible
for black though this i don't like at
all yeah i have no idea why you would do
this to yourself
uh i'm guessing this keeps pieces on the
board and you know generates a position
where you can pretend you have an attack
on the king's side but
yeah you you're mainly pretending
[Music]
g4 desperate
magnus calculating b5 gh3
if h3 there should be five d knight g4
is the intention and b5 plate
i'm assuming he will just take yeah i
this is all very confusing i wouldn't
have guessed
more or less any of the last few moves
um
but now white white appears to be very
much back in control because you have to
if you have to take on e5 to win back
the g4 pawn then
you will have to trade queens and that
end game is extremely cheerless in fact
the knight on g4 just gets caught
in in the end of that line yeah it's
just probably lost for black
[Music]
yeah not good
not good at all just a completely lost
end game now for black or roxy one yeah
you you might as well just wrap things
up here and
go go next
go next life is peaceful there
i think they might have changed the
lyrics in your neck of the woods
[Music]
possibly yeah although it was kind of
when that came out
there was there was definitely a bit of
titillation going on
because people weren't very very used to
the idea of the
the hymn being treated that way carlson
wins another game the score
yeah speaks a clear language
yeah back to 1b3 and uh
magnus showing uh showing how it's done
by by pushing this b5 e4 i was not
really aware that was an option i will
i'm learning all kinds of things about
one b3 today
bishop takes h2 potentially is already a
threat for all we know
so you have to be careful this is all
theory
and
h5 is what the cool kids do sacrificing
upon
but saying i have bishops
[Music]
he does have bishops yeah
i'm not quite sure why not f5